[Musik]
neue normalität in deutschland wer
einkaufen geht oder mit bus und bahn
fährt muss von heute an einen mundschutz
tragen
zurück auf die schulbank wie klappt der
unterricht nach wochenlanger zwangspause
wegen der korona pandemie und achtung
autofahrer wer zu schnell fährt ist sein
führerschein bald er los ab morgen
gelten verschärfte vorschriften auf
deutschlands straßen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den nachrichten zu beginn einer neuen
woche mit einer neuen bundesweiten regel
lange war über ihren nutzen gegen das
krone virus diskutiert worden
ab heute heißt es auch in deutschland
nicht ohne meine maske denn zuletzt hat
sich die ansicht durchgesetzt wenn alle
eine tragen ist jeder ein stück weit
besser geschützt
die vorschrift wird von den
bundesländern aber unterschiedlich
ausgelegt zwar gilt meist der mund nasen
schutz für den öffentlichen nahverkehr
und beim einkaufen nicht einheitlich ist
aber zum beispiel ab welchem alter
kinder eine maske tragen müssen und wie
hoch die geldbuße ist wenn man ohne
erwischt wird in bayern drohen 150 euro
strafe in rheinland pfalz nur 10 euro
thomas münten doppelte premiere für
diesen elektromarkt mitten in köln
endlich wiedereröffnung auf kleiner
fläche und erster tag der masken pflicht
kontrolle am eingang auch um bußgelder
für die geschäfte zu vermeiden völlig
problemlos wir kontrollieren ist
natürlich jederzeit aber wir hatten
keinerlei diskussionen die kollegen und
vor allem unsere mitarbeiter und alle
besucher des hauses sind völlig
verantwortungsvoll und nicht nur die
kunden hier sind einsichtig auch wenn
der ein oder andere den sinn der masken
anzweifelt das macht natürlich alles
sind wissen wir nicht aber wie wir und
bisher beteiligen wir uns auch alle der
randsteine sagte auf jede andere auch
nicht aber im großen und ganzen aber
mache ich auch die leute die halten sich
auch an die ganze sache wenn man jetzt
hier in köln ist ich bin ich auch zur
schon heute und
also echt erstaunt dass so wenig leute
hier sind ich finde es gut ich
befürworte das
weil es ja nicht nur für mich und schutz
ist sondern eben auch für andere und ich
finde es ist eine rechtsfrage noch sind
längst nicht alle passagiere maskiert
aber die meisten die heute zum beispiel
in köln mit bus und bahn gefahren sind
haben sich an wie masken pflicht
gehalten verkehrsbetriebe bundesweit
setzen vorerst noch auf einsicht statt
strafe der erfahrung von heute hat
gezeigt in den fahrzeugen 90 95 prozent
hatten mund nasenschutz an auf den
haltestellen sah es noch nicht ganz so
gut aus weil viele offenbar noch nicht
bewusst ist dass diese regelung auch für
die haltestellen geht in saarbrücken gab
es heute die längsten schlangen vor den
verwaltungsgebäuden
das saarland hatte sich entschlossen mit
dem beginn der masken pflicht die bürger
auch zu unterstützen nicht nur zu sagen
du bürger musst etwas tun sondern dass
es auch eine starthilfe gibt mit fünf
masken die jeder einwohner des
saarlandes bekommt insgesamt sollen in
den nächsten tagen im saarland rund fünf
millionen mund nasenschutz masken
verteilt werden
in leipzig sind mehr als zehn millionen
medizinische schutzmasken aus china
eingetroffen
die bundeswehr hatte dafür eine
frachtmaschine gemietet die lieferung
ist teil einer bestellung von insgesamt
25 millionen masken zu dem termin war
auch verteidigungsministerin kramp
karrenbauer gekommen
dabei gab es ein gedrängel in dem keine
schutz abstände eingehalten wurden
die bundeswehr entschuldigte sich später
dafür
umstritten ist die masken pflicht ist
jedoch die 800 quadratmeter regelung für
geschäfte nach einer entscheidung des
verwaltungsgerichts lockert bayern jetzt
seine regeln auch große geschäfte können
hier jetzt öffnen wenn sie ihre
ladenfläche auf 800 quadratmeter
beschränken
gerichte in niedersachsen und dem
saarland lehnen ähnliche klagen hingegen
ab eine weitere lockerung in der korona
krise ist die öffnung der schulen bis
zum 4
mai wollen bund und länder hier den
betrieb wieder aufnehmen
zunächst allerdings nur für die
abschlussklassen und unter einhaltung
der schutzmaßnahmen es gibt kleine
gruppen in verschiedenen räumen und
zeiten sport und musikunterricht
entfallen
bereits in der vergangenen woche
starteten die schulen in einigen ländern
heute kamen weitere hinzu
wenn regen hat den praxistest gemacht
die schüler kommen zurück begrüßung
inklusive doch in wirklichkeit geht es
schon vor der schultür um die wichtigste
disziplin abstand halten
und wenn man verschiedene stationen
davor schon jemand darauf achtet
schultor geht und dann hier möglich die
10a ist zur hälfte da die andere hälfte
kommt morgen alles im täglichen wechsel
sie sitzen einzeln um genügend abstand
zu halten am platz brauchen sie daher
nicht unbedingt eine gesichtsmaske
das alles ist ungewohnt und doch merkt
man schülern und lehrern an wie froh
alle wieder sind etwas normalität zu
spüren
das ist ganz wichtig für uns unglaublich
auch viele schüler weil wir so lange mit
den schon gearbeitet haben
es ist aber schon total komisch mit
mundschutz über die flure zu laufen und
abstand zu halten
die zweite hälfte der klasse ist online
dabei die schüler bereiten sich auf den
mittleren schulabschluss vor die korona
pause platz der in diese
vorbereitungszeit war dass am ende ein
bisschen stressig finde ich viel zu
viele aufgaben bekommen auf verschiedene
websites und so genau aber ich freue
mich auch hier zu sagen endlich dazu
bezogen
es war schwierig weil ich brauche hilfe
weil ich seit fünf jahren hier bin und
nicht so lange
deswegen sprach bisher hilfe also ist
ungewohnt
weihnachten ist denn durch das 19 nicht
so die krankenkassen haben kann
aber das muss ja sein und das
antivirusprogramm oder immer einen
viertklässler abstand die lehrer sind
kreativ und versuchen ihre schüler da
abzuholen wo sie sprachlich zu hause
sind eine werbeagentur hat geholfen und
fertigwaren die mahnenden aufkleber naja
der erhobene zeigefinger so und das
absperrbaren das sieht man überall in
der stadt und wir fanden dass man dem
ganzen thema auch mit der gewissen
lockerheit zu begegnen sollte locker
aber nicht zu locker in den pausen
müssen die lehrer noch viel
überzeugungsarbeit leisten in puncto
abstand zum mal an dieser schule ab
kommender woche auch die neunten und die
vierten klassen zurückkommen viele
warten täglich auf diese zahlen auch auf
die der neu angesteckten und die sinkt
gegenüber dem monatsbeginn weiter nach
angaben der johns hopkins universität
waren es anfang april in deutschland
fast 6400 neue fälle täglich gestern
kamen rund 1300 fälle dazu insgesamt
sind mehr als 158.000 corona in 40
infizierte durch tests bestätigt davon
gelten mehr als 114.000 betroffene als
genesen 5.985 menschen sind in
verbindung mit dem virus gestorben die
briten haben ihren premierminister
wieder boris johnson der selbst am krone
virus erkrankt war und sogar auf die
intensivstation musste meldet sich in
der downing street zurück und schließt
ein schnelles ende der strengen ausgangs
beschränkungen in großbritannien aus
nach all den anstrengungen dürfe man nun
nichts riskieren sagte er
aber es gibt auch vorwürfe weil die
regierung anfangs wertvolle zeit
verloren habe
andreas stamm
auf dem weg zurück zur arbeit zumindest
für ihn geht es weiter boris johnson ist
wieder da und vor ihm ein berg an
problemen einkaufsstraßen leer leben zu
so kann es nicht weitergehen erklären
parteifreunde und wirtschaftsvertreter
fordern die ausgangs beschränkungen
müssen umgehend gelockert werden
ich will die wirtschaft so schnell es
geht wieder auf kurs bringen aber die
anstrengungen opfer der briten dürfen
nicht vergeben sein
indem wir eine zweite große
infektionswelle riskieren mit vielen
toten und einen zusammenbruch des
gesundheitssystems die botschaft geduld
bewahren keine schnelle öffnung mit ihm
dafür sei die zahl der täglichen
neuansteckungen und todesfälle noch zu
hoch mehr als 20.000 corona tote zählt
das land die eigentliche zahl dürfte
weit höher liegen da beispielsweise
fälle in pflegeheimen nicht mitgezählt
werden eines der opfer
joseph kony krankenschwester auf einer
corona station die am ende das schicksal
das sie ihren patienten ersparen wollte
rossis kinder werfen der regierung
versäumnisse vor sie hätte einen
gesichtsschutz tragen müssen der ihr
ganzes gesicht bedeckt sie hat aber nur
papiermaske handschuhe und eine schürze
gehabt ich will niemandem die schuld
zuweisen aber wenn die verantwortlichen
ihren job ordentlich gemacht hätten wäre
es nicht so ausgegangen
das problem der fehlenden schutzkleidung
ist ungelöst die versprochenen 100.000
tests täglich bis mai nicht zu schaffen
und dazu der vorwurf johnson habe die
gefahr unterschätzt fünf treffen des
nationalen sicherheitsrats zu beginn der
krise geschwänzt was mit erklären warum
es so viele tote gibt
der premierminister ist wieder
arbeitsfähig voller tatendrang die
soweit einzig gute nachricht an diesem
tag anders als die briten wagt italien
ab kommenden montag schrittweise
lockerungen nach sieben wochen mit
strengen ausgangs verboten kündigte
premierminister konnte an dass besuche
bei verwandten in der nähe und sport im
freien wieder erlaubt sein werden auch
die wirtschaft sollen langsam wieder
anlaufen bars und restaurants bleiben
aber bis juni geschlossen
schulen öffnen erst im september wieder
was wird eigentlich mit dem sommerurlaub
das virus macht gerade viele ratlos und
stürzt eine ganze branche in eine
heftige krise die tourismusminister der
eu suchen nun nach antworten noch gibt
es hoffnung dass der korona sommer nicht
völlig verloren ist auch in belgien das
virus geplagte land denkt darüber nach
wie ein urlaub an den großen nord 6
trennten aussehen könnte gunnar krüger
war da den kalender hat stephanie
seymour nicht angerührt seit mitte märz
der letzte gast bezahlte die hotelkette
ist zu 100 angestellte sind in
kurzarbeit
es schmerzt dass wir schließen müssen
und all diese lehren hotels zu sehen
aber das härteste ist dass wir nicht
wissen wann wir wieder aufmachen dürfen
belgien kämpft mit corona und doch
wächst gerade daraus hoffnung wenn
keiner ins ausland darf kommen
vielleicht alle an die küste schon
streiten bürgermeister ob nur besitzer
von ferienwohnungen einen strand dürfen
ich finde die idee so das ist zu
verrückt um darüber zu reden geben das
wäre diskriminierung mein kollege meint
nur wer steuern zahlt das an den strand
ist der gehört publik domain
das zeigt es gibt was zu regeln für
europas tourismusminister kroatien
wollte sie alle an der adria willkommen
heißen und bremst nun per video ein
wettrennen um lockerungen österreich
etwa will reisefreiheit für einen klub
der länder mit wenig infizierten so
könnte sich auch deutschland den
neustart der branche vorstellen
der kann nur schritt für schritt
vorangehen wird sie auch sehr stark
daran orientieren wie die
infektionskette derzeit aussieht und ich
glaube dass es auch da eine regionale
und dann er dann auch nationale und dann
auch europäische öffnung geben kann
belgiens strand streit ist den des
bislang keiner um nichts im
buchungssystem von stephanie seymour
bleibt der ansturm aus wir haben ein
paar buchungen aber auch viele absagen
von ausländern die nicht wissen ob sie
über die grenzen
in einer branche die genau wissen will
wann wie viele betten belegt sind ist
ungewissheit am schwersten zu verkraften
sommerurlaub in corona zeiten fragen an
außenminister maß in wiso spezial
gleich im anschluss an unsere
nachrichten und alles was sie zum thema
wissen müssen können sie in der zdf-
heute- app nachlesen
fest steht schon jetzt der sommerurlaub
wird diesmal wohl ganz anders aussehen
als sonst der angeschlagene
ferienflieger condor bekommt weitere
staatshilfen
die eu-kommission genehmigte im
schnellverfahren einen kfw-kredit von
550 millionen euro
condor sollte nach der pleite des thomas
cook konzerns eigentlich von der
polnischen lot übernommen werden
das scheiterte aber weil diese nun
selbst staatshilfe benötigt die airlines
leiden und werden wohl deutlich weniger
neue flugzeuge brauchen beim hersteller
airbus leuten deshalb die alarmglocken
firmenchef guillaume faury stimmte die
belegschaft des europäischen
luftfahrtkonzerns auf harte zeiten ein
über nacht sei ein drittel des geschäfts
weggebrochen
airbus müsse seine ausgaben rasch senken
sonst stehe die existenz des
unternehmens auf dem spiel als fantasie
der medien hatte brasiliens präsident
ball so naro die korona pandemie
mehrfach abgetan als bitter ernste
realität leben sie jedoch die menschen
im land dort sind mehr als 63.000
infektionen registriert 4298 menschen
starben an den folgen
weil wenig getestet wird gehen experten
aber von deutlich mehr fällen aus klar
ist kliniken warnen vor dem kollaps
beatmungs plätze fehlen
und mancher orts müssen sie die toten in
massengräbern bestattet wie unser
korrespondent christoph reckert
berichtet
es sind bilder die sich langsam ins
bewusstsein der brasilianer einbrennen
massengräber in manaus am amazonas im
ganzen land melden die friedhöfe einen
erhöhten bedarf an gräbern und lassen
damit erahnen wie es wirklich um
brasilien steht denn die offiziellen
zahlen sind noch verhältnismäßig niedrig
es wird zu wenig getestet
auch in rio de janeiro steht das
gesundheitswesen kurz vor dem kollaps
leichen liegen auf den fluren diese
bilder schickt uns ein arzt aus einem
krankenhaus
überfüllte stationen ein beatmungsgerät
für 30 patienten zwischen den lebenden
liegen immer wieder auch tote erzählt er
es ist wie in den krieg zu ziehen wir
sehen dass unsere kollegen krank werden
wir sehen dass unsere kollegen sterben
und wir sehen wie die regierung das
unterschätzt
es fehlt an allem
die ärzte müssen ihre schutzausrüstung
wiederverwenden viele patienten sind
auffallend jung brasilien fielen die
mittel und das konzept und die sich
anbahnende katastrophe zu verhindern
präsident portion awo hat das virus
immer wieder kleingeredet
er will das land wieder öffnen und hat
deshalb seinen gesundheitsminister
manndecker entlassen weil der sich für
weitreichende isolationsmaßnahmen
eingesetzt hatte wie es die
wissenschaftler empfehlen die ärzte sind
frustriert leider haben wir in brasilien
eine zeit in der die wissenschaft
aussortiert wird
und jetzt bezahlen vor wenigen tagen hat
boll szenario auch noch seinen populären
justizminister moro verloren es war
nicht wegen corona sondern im streit um
führungsposten bei der polizei doch es
ist ein schwerer schlag für die
regierung und sorgt für instabilität
goldzone als anhänger demonstrieren
weiter für die öffnung des landes
während die ärzte in den krankenhäusern
auf verlorenem posten um das leben der
patienten kämpfen brasilien taumelt
kopflos durch die korona krise die
weltweiten militärausgaben haben einen
neuen höchststand erreicht das berichtet
das stockholmer
friedensforschungsinstitut sipri
demnach haben die staaten 2009 10 fast
zwei billionen dollar für rüstungsgüter
ausgegeben 3,6 prozent mehr als im jahr
davor
spitzenreiter sind weiter die usa mit
einem budget von
732 milliarden us dollar gefolgt von
china und indien
deutschland hat für sein militär 49,3
milliarden dollar ausgegeben
ein plus von 10 prozent im vergleich zum
vorjahr verkehrssünder müssen künftig
tiefer in die tasche greifen ab morgen
gelten neue vorschriften auf
deutschlands straßen etwa auf den
autobahnen
wer eine rettungsgasse nutzt um
schneller voranzukommen der zahlt
kräftig 200 bis 320 euro dazu ein monat
fahrverbot und zwei punkte wer seinen
wagen auf geh und radwegen parkt bekommt
ein bußgeld von 55 euro statt bisher 20
ein überblick von david sauer zu
schnelles fahren ist einer der
hauptgründe für schwere unfälle
wer keine rücksicht nimmt muss sich
jetzt auf härtere strafen einstellen
innerorts gilt ab morgen wer 16
kilometer pro stunde zu schnell fährt
kriegt 70 euro bußgeld
außerorts liegt das bußgeld bei 60 euro
ab 21 km/h trüber witz innerorts richtig
unangenehm ein punkt und 80 euro bußgeld
plus ein monat fahrverbot
außerorts greifen diese strafen ab 26 km
h zu viel
zum vergleich vorher musste man dafür 41
km/h zu schnell fahren
die verschärfung geht auf die länder
zurück im bundesrat haben sie noch mal
nachgelegt der adac beklagt die
neuregelung sei zu pauschal unterschied
war man von der schule oder im
kindergarten unterwegs oder hat man sich
auf einer zb gut ausgebauten ringstraße
innerstädtisch befunden
gemischte reaktionen bei den bürgern als
fahrradfahrer kann ich das logo für
worden
ich hole strafe die 30 zu glaube ich
niemand 30 oder andere sowieso schon die
noch probleme würde ich der meinung war
und da brauchen da noch mehr
leute die auf den führerschein
angewiesen sind natürlich darunter ein
lkw fahrer auch oder wer auch immer auf
seinen führerschein angewiesen ist
verkehrs schütze begrüßen die änderungen
als wesentliche ursachen von unfällen
angepackt werden zum beispiel die
überhöhten geschwindigkeiten wir müssen
den verkehrsraum neu aufteilen mehr
platz für die zu fuß gehenden mehr platz
für die immer mehr radfahrenden beliebt
aber nun endgültig verboten blitzer apps
die vor radarkontrollen warnen
auch das kann ab morgen teuer werden die
fußball wm 2006 in deutschland ist als
sommermärchen in die sportgeschichte
eingegangen
doch auf die damalige dfb chefetage feld
längst ein dunkler schatten online
dubiose millionenzahlungen
täuschungsmanöver
die justiz in der schweiz dem standort
des weltfußballverbandes fifa sollte
licht ins dunkel bringen
doch das verfahren ist jetzt sang und
klanglos verjährt saar attacke hier
hätte der sommer märchen skandal
aufgeklärt werden sollen
im schweizer bundesstrafgericht in
bellinzona mit dem tag heute aber steht
fest hier wird nichts mehr aufgeklärt
die schweizer sind gescheitert das ist
eine ganz große peinlichkeit
international
ich muss auch sagen die schweizer bürger
haben mühe damit dass ihr institutionen
ihre justiz so inkompetent ist denn die
schweizer justiz konnte in fünf jahren
ermittlungen nicht aufklären ob die wm
2006 das deutsche sommermärchen gekauft
war in der anklageschrift die dem zdf
vorliegt führen die ermittler noch an
dass sich beckenbauer im jahr 2002 6 7
millionen euro vom ehemaligen adidas
chef louis dreyfus li und kurz darauf
insgesamt 67 millionen euro an
verschiedene firmen des fifa funktionär
bin hammam überwies ob das
bestechungsgelder für die wm 2006 waren
genau diese zentrale frage wird von der
schweizer justiz nicht mehr geklärt
vordergründig macht die schweizer justiz
das corona virus für ihr scheitern
verantwortlich damit lenkt sie aber vom
eigenen versagen nur ab denn
mittlerweile wird führenden schweizer
ermittlern vorgeworfen sich selber mit
mächtigen fußball funktionären
eingelassen zu haben
und so wird aus dem unaufgeklärten
angeklagten korruptionsskandal im
fußball ein handfester noch aufzuklären
der justizskandal in der schweiz und der
unaufgeklärte mögliche korruption
skandal rund um die wm 2006 der könnte
wenn überhaupt in einem noch offenen
steuerstrafverfahren in frankfurt
geklärt werden fest steht jetzt
aufklärung in der schweiz wird es nicht
mehr geben
ein geburtstag ohne gäste
das ist zurzeit der regelfall und gilt
auch wenn der könig höchstpersönlich
feiert königs tag in den niederlanden
ohne straßenfest ansonsten aber fast wie
immer die deko stimmt der kuchen
schmeckt
als ständchen tönt die nationalhymne aus
wohnzimmern und vorgärten und das
geburtstagskind willem-alexander
bedankte sich von zuhause für diesen
besonderen tag
gute nachrichten beim wetter endlich
kommt regen morgen geht es los wo es
regnet und wie viel sagt uns gleich
katja horneffer das war es von uns
später gibt es mehr im heute journal um
21.45 mit christian sievers und um 19
uhr ist morgen barbara hahlweg für sie
da danke für ihr interesse und noch
einen angenehmen abend für sie